سأبدأ بالحالة في المنطقة الخاصة
عملية عسكرية التشكيلات الأوكرانية
شن هجمات فاشلة
تجمعات القوات المسلحة الروسية
15 طائرة دمرت ثلاث طائرات هليكوبتر
920 عربة مدرعة ، بما في ذلك
بما في ذلك 16 دبابة ليوبارد عمليا
مائة بالمائة من الدبابات من هذا النوع
التي قدمتها بولندا والبرتغال
فقط من 4 يونيو في جميع الاتجاهات
فقدت القوات الأوكرانية حوالي اثنين
نصف ألف وحدة مختلفة
أسلحة
لا يسعني إلا طرح سؤال آخر من
جميع الإجابات الأخرى التي قدمتها بالفعل
قائدنا الأعلى
نحن نتحدث عن محاولة في 23-25 ​​يونيو
زعزعة استقرار الوضع في روسيا
فشلت تلك الخطط في المقام الأول
لأن أفراد القوات المسلحة
أظهر الولاء للقسم والجيش
دَين
الاستفزازات لم تؤثر على الإجراءات
قوات المجموعة
الجنود بشجاعة و
واصل اتخاذ القرار بإيثار
المهام المعينة